my lung collapsed i have no ribs but we
need to attack
jason i need you to confuse twitter
again on it sir that's
that's cute but we need someone to carry
us past the box hey yo what up man how's
everybody doing this
is the nfc south lead deliver us to the
postseason oh now we get targets
guard him well camaro no one can guard
me oh no
i'm suspended remember you're all
purpose
ow
yo chill out plane oh no not again we're
actually getting it together under
raheem
john's high high run down running man
you're finished kamara
oh wait four yards we're good man my man
gonna give me an 88.
why are we running thank you for keeping
up camera we have the same enemy
good luck and [ __ ] the bugs who
take my division rules i'm going to
blame time for not shooting better
[Music]
the first rule of matte rule is rules
the second rule of matt rule
is not rules the third rule of that rule
is
address the culture first trust your
brain don't worry about winning games
until 2021
correct